i have recently taken a lover
well that's great congratulations
who's the lucky lady pam's mom
what pam's mom helene remember from your
wedding
you're messing with me about what you
did not have sex with pam's mom
oh big time what kind of cars to drive
she drives a green camera
and the seats go all the way down all
the way down oh my god
oh my god what okay
never tell pam and then secondly good
packed a packed
although i may have to break it tonight
when helene and i tell pam over dinner
you all right oh my god hey jim
not now toby my god get the hell out of
here idiot what did i do
okay as far as dinner tonight cancel
that and please for both of our sakes
never ever ever see her again
i think you're underestimating pam i
think more than anything she wants me to
be happy
no not more than anything okay i
i have a good thing with the mom don't
call her she's right on my way home from
work
and take a different way home man all
right
i'll take surface streets it's the last
thing in the world i would want to do is
upset pam
okay so we're good yeah
michael can i okay i'm just gonna skip
right past the what and go with why
because this
is the recreation of a crime scene i'm
the dead body and these are my
brainchild hey shut up you're dead
michael can i talk to you michael here
my name caleb
today shut up they need this game
jim let us have this stupid little game
all right
oh you startled me
oh my stars my heart nearly leapt out of
my
chest what can i do you for wallace is
on the phone he's
returning your call detective wallace i
don't think so i think it's david
wallace
from dunder mifflin oh shucks tell him
i'm not here
you're not gonna answer the phone no i
only answer to detective wallace cause i
got a warm
body in the other room i'll take it
hey pickles merry christmas open
immediately
love swiss cheese
damn it dwight didn't think your
affectionate nicknames would be your
undoing did you jim
let that be a lesson to you all
to me the sixers are a five seed tops
i think they're going to conference
finals buying them
obvious monster i have three point
shooting don't eat
i bit my lip at lunch today
sucks anyway i just don't see it the
knicks are tough
the nets are tough oh the nets are super
tough
now i have this big bump in my lip that
hurts
i hate it the hawks
are terrible they're always terrible
okay you need to
think about it before you come with the
whatever it's not a big deal you know i
always tell my three-year-old if this is
the worst thing that's gonna happen
you gotta be kidding me okay pam
that's it i'm going home
do you love her or do you love the idea
of her
i don't know man i just don't know i
gotta make an example out of him
should i just fire him can you actually
fire people to be honest i don't know
but maybe i could just yell at him in
front of people well i can't really
imagine you yelling at anyone
why yell you've heard me yell okay i've
heard you exclaim
like the time you said hey look we
parked over here
well that was apple picking day there's
no need to yell that day you know i was
just excited to find the car
perfect end to a perfect day
well you'll figure it out
you